previously on TV since Jason in the lake
the one who attacked me the one who
pulled me underneath the water
[Music]
it's like the director asked Ross to
think of the most ridiculous way he
could sit that would also emphasize his
crotch
good luck looking at anything else
during the scene you know you've eaten
too much when you reach into your pants
to check your bits while the company is
still there but it does apparently
teleport considering that when you
started pushing that button the remote
was diagonal from the corner and now
it's fully parallel to the edge of the
table we should play that game where
everyone says one thing that they're
thankful for is that a game I'm pretty
sure that's a conversation starter fun
fact conversation starters were invented
by [ __ ] who can't handle silence I
am thankful for this beautiful fall
we've been having this lovely fall
breeze came in out of nowhere and blew
this chicks skirt right out blah blah
doesn't age well blah blah problematic I
promise we're as tired of saying it as
you are of hearing it but Sydney would
just add the sin anyway so we might as
well mention it Sydney is a bit of an
sjw if you ask me which reminds me I'm
also thankful for thongs
tonight's role of Joey will be played by
the promising and up-and-coming young
thespian Cisco wide they specifically
have this cutaway in the intro of two
characters that spoke a total of eight
words to each other during the entire
series 1978 wait Chandler was 11 in 1978
I mean I thought I was old that dude was
alive during the fake moon landing not
that he missed their chapter oh this kid
from the 70s has the most 90s haircut
I've ever seen Lincoln didn't set
Thanksgiving as a national holiday until
1863 so while it's true that people had
fall Thanksgiving celebrations there
would have been no official Thanksgiving
for proto Phoebe to be aware of also we
all know that unless you're Keanu Reeves
your past lives look nothing like your
current life
okay look I'm not asking for top-tier
Hollywood digital effects or anything
but could you at least aim for somewhere
above an SNL sketch that's complete with
the discount Chris Pratt and a clearly
visible rod pulling off the arm hello
there are so many great Phoebe moments
that Lisa Kudrow brings to life so
perfectly and while this one may not be
as epic as smelly cat or her crazy run
it's time for a sin off for Pheebs and
her wind Z I've just spent several
minutes trying to figure out how big a
turkey would have to be to allow a human
head to fit inside two things first
there are very few turkeys large enough
to do this and second mr. bean did it
better every one of these cast members
are insanely talented but for whatever
reason they decided to downshift into
Community Theatre in Dayton Ohio mode
for this iconic scene this works and
like for a full five seconds and Ross
had to say butternut squash yeah yeah
joke punchline laugh track repeat but
can we just agree that butternut should
be a type of candy bar or ice cream
flavor or even a men's anti chiefing
running cream but not a frickin gourd
[Music]
just call it sex considering the
proximity of this conversation to the
table setting either the Geller parents
have serious hearing problems or jack is
in to hearing about these details and
even though only one of those is a sin
I'm betting on that one does it feel
weird around here now you know since
I've been away at college if by weird
you mean a high school student has been
safe from all your stocky talki then yes
also these two suck apparently they've
always sucked they go together about as
well as hot sauce and heinie holes this
time it would last at least for an
entire song assuming chip has a little
game he'll play Murray's William stay
which is 1 minute and 37 seconds long so
don't get too excited there Rachel so
I'm thinking of asking Rachel out
tonight isn't this Monica story to tell
if so how does she know any of the
frozen Channel okay why don't you finish
off these facts I don't have anyone in
the fridge considering this woman
obviously lives on Mount Olympus doesn't
she have other options besides putting
pie down her child's throat and call you
fat
I don't even remember that well I do I'm
so sorry I really am
you know who else should be sorry this
horrible person all of these old wounds
are reopened because Rachel said I know
Monica's worse Thanksgiving and then sat
back and watch the drama unfold her name
is Carol she's she's on the lacrosse
team and the golf team that she plays
for both teams seems like what the
team's Ross means isn't a huge fan of
pean well like anything can be sexy like
this like this dish towel or perhaps
this naturally phallic carrot that is
sitting right there Monica sure does
stick her tongue out a lot but does this
action really convey high school youth
like she's hoping all I'm picking up is
horribly uncomfortable cat carrots
sometimes I like to put them between my
fingers like this and hold them down
here while I talk to you for all the
deserve crap I give Monica about the
constant yelling and over-the-top tongue
antics I gotta say Courtney Cox is a
pretty great physical comedian and I
guess it's Monica's turn first at all
using psychos music during a shot with a
knife cliche could you please do that
first you know where his injury is old
Geller would be excellent at TV sins oh
yes I have it right here oh nice and the
doctor will take it with no gloves on
despite wearing them in scenes both
directly before and after this that's
why I lost my toe because I called you
fat no even lost your toe because you
stood like a statue as a butcher knife
plummeted into your foot that toe
capitation was entirely preventable yeah
well I missed the tip it's the best part
I think my college girlfriend said about
my has the nail ouch
never mind sir limps a lot I came up
with that since writers I hate this
stupid day and everything about it 20
minutes ago you were nodding along with
the crew about how wonderful Monica's
meal was you're selective Thanksgiving
hatred seems more like a Chandler
tantrum tantrum you're so great I love
you
I know I know I'm supposed to be so
invested in this moment of vocalized
love but how are these glasses enhance
staying on she put them on like this and
now the Hat is defying gravity the
glasses are stabbed into the wings also
they've already eaten so is the show
saying they had an extra turkey for just
such a call back or did maka run to
whatever New York's version of Walmart
is to get another bird you could have
just waited Monica cuz I'm giving you
the bird right now what is these
leftovers enjoy it there's no flavor
there are no spices where are the chips
now Chandler dear just because your
father and I are getting a divorce
doesn't mean we don't love you
it just means you are such a pushover I
know you are what am I butterfingers
[Music]
Ross tried to say butternut squash and
he came out squatter nut Bosch Benedict
Cumberbatch benefit Lumberjacks jawed
bit cumbered it Humber